there's no holiday quite like the purge
and that's a good thing but what if it
were real this one night out of the year
in which all crime including murder was
legal would you hide or would you seek
the Burge scratches the same itch as a
zombie movie imagining a lawless world
where it's kill or be killed if the
perch really did pop up would you be
prepared over four stories of survival
and anarchy we've noticed some
strategies that would help you survive
along with a few tactics to avoid at all
costs grab your notebook and pay
attention to the do's and don'ts of
purge night due prior preparation ask
any manager type about the five P's and
they'll tell you proper planning
prevents poor performance it's a
principle that can be applied to
everything from food service to the
front lines so if the sirens go off and
you haven't yet built up a stockpile of
useful goods then you deserve whatever
is coming to you Frank Grillo's
character Leo Barnes demonstrates the
preparation principle perfectly there's
also the first purchase Dimitri who
prepared for perching by getting his
hands on every gun that's ever washed up
on Staten Island so follow their
examples you should also probably learn
some martial arts don't cultivate
grudges purge or no purge the key to not
being killed by your neighbors is to not
give your neighbors a reason this can be
accomplished by just being a considerate
person and not giving people any cause
to think about your name when the old
murder is legal holiday comes around
otherwise you could end up like the
sanded family ringed in by resentful
neighbors with targets on your back
probably should have participated in the
neighborhood rummage sale guys do the
buddy system braving the purge alone
could be a one-way ticket to the morgue
you never know when a marauding team of
dirt bikers paramilitary goons or the
KKK might be lurking if you want to
survive you need friends the purge
Anarchy is all about the value of
friendship in the trenches with sergeant
Barnes going from a vengeance driven
lone wolf to a righteous defender of the
weak and turned the people he protects
have his back and ultimately save his
soul the only person who makes the
one-man army route work for him is the
first purchase Dmitri who goes full
Rambo on a tower full of armed invaders
but that only ends up being the case
after his entire team is assassinated
via drone strike and not even
he gets the job done all by himself
don't get cocky across all of the purge
movies it's shocking how many
participants serve themselves up as easy
targets twirling in the streets and
basically asking for a bullet don't let
this be you instead up your chances of
survival by staying humble and praying
for Dawn
don't get caught up in the acts of
pretentious ritual murder which backfire
far too frequently and don't be out in
the road in a tank top and a bunny mask
flexing and taunting people that's how
you get a crossbow bolt to the chest
from the real heroes murder is legal for
everyone remember do armor up even mall
cops wear bulletproof vests when they go
to work so why do so many perjures dress
like they're going to a warehouse rave
instead of an unhinged massacre perjures
put all their focus on the masks when
they should really be hitting the
streets dressed like Robocop
they don't even wear helmets in that way
purging is like riding a bicycle are you
trying to look cool or do you want to
get home alive don't be obsessive after
going through each purge movie with a
team of experts we've determined that
purge night is actually not a great time
to settle scores countless people die on
some lonely Hills over the course of the
films just because they couldn't let
things go from the candy obsessed girl
and election year to the first movies
squad of prep school creeps who couldn't
let one guy get away sure you've been
waiting all year to let the beast out
and yes your landlord probably deserves
it but if they get away the first time
you've got a chill relax there's always
next year
do leave the country sometimes the only
way to win is not to play so if you got
the means and the motive take the
opportunity and get out of the country
on purge night spend the night offshore
in international waters which is move
and say goodbye to the US of A you'll be
home eventually
how long in this tradition really lasts
don't go outside the plots of purged
movies don't kick in until the outside
world intrudes if you want to avoid that
then stay in and plan ahead to avoid the
need for a beer pizza or ammo run
there's a reason why none of these
movies have focused too much on what
goes down inside most people's homes
during purge night and that's because
for most people the purge is a downright
cozy experience its people and fuzzy
socks with ar-15s eating snacks and
bring out the DVR for the most part
regular people don't really go after
each other during the purge
it's live-and-let-live with four movies
of documentary evidence to go on it's
clear the purge is for crazy people
so let the crazy people have it you
don't have to go out there just stay
inside and watch TV
[Music]